en el segundo día de su audiencia ante
el senado la candidata a la corte
suprema de joe biden que tang yi brawn
jackson tuvo que hacer frente a horas de
escrutinio con preguntas de demócratas y
republicanos que la emocionaron
para los que buscan una etiqueta de
entrada me gustaría comentar cuál es su
posición sobre la filosofía judicial
una materia sobre la que fue muy
cuestionada varios senadores
republicanos la acusaron de ser
demasiado laxa en sus condenas en casos
de pornografía infantil e incluso de
simpatizar con este tipo de delincuentes
simplemente por no aplicar la máxima
pena posible en todos los casos
como madre jueza que ha tenido que
lidiar con estos casos dices
hey sé que nada puede estar más allá de
la verdad freder sounders a lo largo de
la jornada los republicanos también le
increparon por su posición sobre el
racismo y por ser según ellos demasiado
liberal para el cargo además tras el
11-s jackson represento al órgano que al
igual que tras más de una década en
guantánamo terminó siendo enviado a casa
sin cargos algo que los republicanos
tildaron como apoyo al terrorismo pero
de lo que la jueza se siente orgullosa
por defender la verdad y la libertad que
hay como jueza me importa mucho el
estado de derecho y sé que para que el
sistema funcione tenemos que hacer que
la gente rinda cuentas por cometer
delitos pero tenemos que hacerlo de
forma justa como indica la constitución
a pesar de que la cámara alta está muy
dividida se espera que jackson consiga
sin dificultad los votos para suceder al
conservador estefan breyer de lograrlo
la que fue jueza federal de apelaciones
por ocho años se convertiría en la
primera mujer negra en formar parte del
máximo órgano judicial del país